we're all big nesters everyone on the
planet's a big nestor right now
deborah we have a design story take it
away yeah this is kind of cute this was
in glamour magazine and glamour magazine
just did a story in which they said it
is time to bring back
dried flowers they are gorgeous they
bring life and color to your space you
can't go to the flower store right now
anyway because it's scary to go outside
and they never get old because they're
already dead
yes i do think that an entryway
and dried flowers or any type of flowers
i'm with you and i practice what i
preach so i did this installation with
hammer and nail
that's beautiful thank you oh that's
great what is that that's um
on the windows there i don't know uh
but it's dry it's pretty and it's like a
deep
auburn maroon color anyway um ross
before we go there is an incredible new
piece in uh the new yorker
uh it's a great long read you should
check it out but the main takeaway here
is that it is
never too late no matter what age you
are it's never too late to learn a brand
new skill
and i think so many people get to the
point of like oh i'm out of high school
i'm out of college i'm done
learning i am what i am when we go
through life but is there a skill
that you think maybe if i could i'd give
it a go
mine would be piano um yeah because i
want to be that person at a party where
they like play and i'm like no and then
i do
for like hours yeah that would be great
yeah do you think it's too late
i mean i did before i read the story now
i think i should do it
what would you do drew um i've always
wanted to learn spanish
like you can do that i know and my
daughter says the same thing she's like
i'm so sick of hearing you talk about it
just
do it yeah and i'm like oh gosh you're
right
should we challenge each other to do it
in 2021
no you learn to sing in spanish and
he'll play
yeah that's good deborah what would you
learn in 2021
i don't know i i've always wanted to
play the guitar and right now all my
nails are broken so it actually would be
a good good time to do it by the way we
could be a band
okay right i see this the deborah
norville trio
don't quit your day job i think this is
all doable a little guitar a little
piano
a little spanish i mean this is all
doable
my daughter is right we just have to do
it but i think the thing is i think it's
the accomplishment i don't think it's
the task itself i think it's the
accomplishment for me when i'm really
getting cranky or not feeling very
grateful or
or what have you i'll go and make
something i'll go
and you know knit something or i'll go
and my house is under renovation right
now
i have taken joy out of taking paint off
of old hinges
so i think it's the accomplishment of
something
so even if all you learned to say is
mayamo drew hey that's good
you learn to say that in spanish and you
should celebrate yourself for that and
not beat yourself up because you can't
go and read don quixote in the original
language
yes thank you for putting it in that
perspective and
speaking of um making things we never
want this show to end and we always like
to send you home with something that we
like to call doggie bags i love doggy
bags
thank you okay and today it's something
to do
in honor of what you just said debra i
just got this
needlepoint kit i got it off etsy
and this bender is fantastic um it's
called
unwind and she has all sorts of
different needle points that are really
artistic but
you know you you there's pretty plenty
on on
etsy for all different styles and
you can order them and i even ordered
like
thread that goes with it and i'm just
really excited to attack this
good for you there's your thing instead
of spanish or you can listen to spanish
while you do your needlepoint
multitask deborah norville i'm so
honored to be sharing especially
a news desk with you and knowing how
much you value gratitude
and good news and good stories it was an
honor to get to tell some of those with
you today
very kind thank you drew it's a delight
to be here thank you
oh my goodness gonna make us
cry for a second time today
on weeknights on inside edition
thank god for you i'm not alone in here
thank god for everyone here
i feel so lucky and for anyone who tunes
in at home
thank you for spending time with us and
we hope
that you can take the good energy that
happens in here out with you for the
rest of your day
and make that gratitude list that's
three thank you that's doable
have a great day